our next speaker who's Corney parquette
from Miguel and gold
M great um so I want to thank the
organizers for inviting me so thank you
um also please ask questions during this
talk I I hope
that I want people to learn things
and so please please ask a lot of
questions um so before we begin I just
also want to say that this has been sort
of like a project that I've been doing
for the last couple of years maybe three
or four years um involves people from
like Deep Mind Migel postto grad
students
Etc okay so what are some of the
problems that we're facing in
optimization and machine learning and I
would say one of the biggest problems
that we see is that there is a gap
between what is actually happening in
theory and what is actually happening in
practice in practice practitioners
basically ignore everything that the
atici say I'm hoping there's not too
many practitioners in the room but it's
is basically true at this point on the
other hand we can't really blame
practitioners and there's a reason from
the theory side which I sort of count
myself as what we do is we tend to
produce plots which look like this so
these are runs of the algorithm just INF
runs of the same algorithm on the same
problem and we're plotting suboptimality
and we always do better like we always
put up our plots of ML and we say hey
look our results are always better than
what we our Theory actually says and I'm
being very generous with my theory here
I'm actually putting it on the same
scale okay in general this is like not
even on the same scale and these are not
to say that these worst case bounds are
bad they're actually attained okay but
somehow in ml like we never see it and
we're always somehow better okay what I
want to say from that is that maybe we
should instead of just saying well and
practice everything is much better we
should go back and actually say why do
we have that like what is the reason
that we always see things better okay
and what I want to argue with you guys
today with or maybe suggest something
about it is that one of the reasons why
we see this sort of thing is that we
probably have a mismatch with what our
assumptions are in optimization we
assume things like well they're just
smooth nons smooth uh uh convex
non-convex and that's how we break up
our class as the function but maybe we
need to go back and say what is actually
happening in these ml problem like what
are those assumptions do they actually
hold okay the other thing I want to
point out is that often we're not super
interested in convergence also we're
interested in other quantities so
there's stuff um I'm going to talk about
that too okay so what is the goal again
the goal is can we actually bridge this
gap between what is happening in theory
and what is happening in practice okay
all right so if there's anything you get
out of this this talk I'm hoping it's
this slide okay so what is the idea here
what I want to do is I want to be able
to predict at any iteration of SGD of a
stochastic algorithm the exact loss
function without ever running
SGD okay so that's exactly what's
happening here and I want to do it on a
single run I want to do it with real
data okay so that's exactly what's
happening here okay you know I can't do
this in general so I'm going to do this
sort of in for very simple functions at
least to start off with what am I
allowed to actually use about the data
I'm allowed to use the Spectrum so this
is the Spectrum with CFR data okay I'm
allowed to use initializations and I'm
allowed to use targets but again what I
want to do is at each iteration of the
SGD algorithm I want to be able to tell
you exactly what that loss is without
ever running it and we can do that so
this is the plot of this so what's
happening here is your iterations this
is a empirical risk so I'm reusing data
here I'm doing an empirical risk
minimization a single run of this is
just me doing CFR data off of it that's
what the squiggly lines are that's
actually SGD and my prediction is
exactly this straight
curve okay I can predict it even on a
single run okay again in any iteration I
can tell you what that curve is without
running
it okay okay first any questions stop
here everyone clear with the idea you're
saying you're reusing data you're um yes
I'm reusing data so I'm doing just like
I'm choosing an index uniformly at
random and updating that's how I'm doing
my stochastic so I will eventually reuse
all my data and repeat
it any
other start n oh sorry just a question
so what is the model that you are
optimizing yeah so at the moment I'm
going to do is the Le squares I'm going
to extend it a little bit so this is
actually a random features model uh so
I'm taking my data and I'm just hitting
it with a random Matrix doing an
activation function off of it R will
work and then minimizing just sort of
the last layer this one
yeah any
others okay good all right the other
thing I'm going to say is that my
prediction is going to be like if SGD
diverges my prediction will also diverge
so they correspond okay yeah somewhere
in the ination ah no uh these are going
to be last iterate and they're going to
hold with overwhelming
probability I mean function minimize the
expectation of the you know yeah so
because this is a two Norm it's summing
it all up so yeah it's doing an
expectation yeah into it in there yeah
okay so I I normalized my data sorry I
normalized this so it has like a one
over n Behavior yeah good see I know I
should stop on the second slide
okay um the other thing I want to point
out about this is that I'm an Optimizer
I don't want to lose my job this isn't
really about being able to exactly
predict this Behavior doing these
predictions is extremely costly okay as
more cost than actually running the
algorithm the goal here though remember
is that we want to actually be able to
say here's what SGD does so if I'm able
to actually predict using data what SGD
does I can actually use that prediction
to gain insights about the actual
algorithm itself how do we choose step
sizes why our convergence are much
better than we see okay that's the
ultimate goal is that once you have this
prediction you can actually use
it okay all
right
slide three okay so now comes the
question of I started with well what are
the typical assumptions that we should
be
making so the idea here is that you know
in optimization we're just minimizing
some problem but what is actually
typical in a lot of the machine learning
problems is that they're what are called
high-dimensional that means that both
the number of features so the space for
which you're minimizing over D and the
number of samples are also large
simultaneously okay so just to give you
an understanding of that what I'm
actually going to assume is that the
ratio of features to samples is actually
growing both large simultaneously to
some constant okay so samples and
features are growing and if you actually
plot this along state-of-the-art models
it's a little old now data points versus
parameters and you did a a fit a
polinomial fit you would actually see a
linear y so like the real data sets and
the real like state-of-the-art models
they've been optimized for various other
things seem to follow this trajectory of
saying data points and number of samples
grow both large
simultaneously that's been the trend
recently okay so making this assumption
is not so
bad okay so the goal here is that
everything is large High dimensional so
I am not going to be able to show these
results hold when Dimension is small I'm
not going to care about when Sol the
problem when Dimension is two 5 10
that's fine I'm going to only be caring
about when the dimension is like
thousand a million Etc that's the idea
here okay so what makes high Dimensions
very different well you have more room
so you have more possibilities that
means inputs which you generate worst
case complexity are very very far from
the typical one this is like an average
case idea so just to give you an idea of
how you actually see this let's look at
some ideas from high Dimensions versus
low Dimensions so here's a question for
everyone how many vectors can you find
which are simultaneously almost
orthogonal in D Dimensions that is to
say if I look at X transpose y I want
less than Epsilon that's what I mean by
almost orthogonal how many of those
vectors occur in high
Dimensions
yes hopefully there's some probabbly out
in the room or if you want to know the
answer it's exponential indeed wow
that's a lie okay we always think of
orthogonality as being kind of special
but in high Dimensions it's not special
alternatively you probably have seen
this from maybe a high dimensional class
this is the equivalent of the statement
if you fix a vector X on the sphere you
draw another Vector y uniformly from
that sphere then their inner product is
almost always one over square root D
okay that means lots of things in high
dimensions are almost orthogonal
chuse any fixed Direction what does that
mean for us okay let's go back to our
problem okay we're solving a loss
minimization problem we run SGD by
choosing an index uniformly at random
and you generate a stochastic gradient
what that means or what we usually think
of is we say well this is hold an
expectation to roughly be the loss so
let's treat this like gradient descent
right but if we're in high Dimensions we
actually don't have this little fact why
because everything is almost orthogonal
to each other so this stochastic
gradient has very very little actually
pointing in the direction of the full
gradient most of it is actually
orthogonal to
it we should use this this is a weird
fact this is high
Dimensions
okay clear yeah are you see that our IID
or yeah the data is generated uh you can
think of it as the data is generated IID
usually um I will they can have
covariant in the feature side yeah so
what are your assumptions assumptions on
covariance then uh I'm just gonna assume
B I'll show you the setup in a second
yeah great question
okay we'll see the exact setup I won't
be able to do it for everything all
right so the question though is how do
you actually capture High dimensional
structure so the way you think of it
from an optimization Viewpoint is that
high dimensionality actually gives you
some extra structure on your problem and
that you need to use it structure in the
same sense of convexity non-convexity
smoothness non-s smoothness whether it's
a finite sum High dimensionality also
does the same but how do you actually
capture it so the way people generally
do it is we we're going to seal the
ideas from statistical learning theory
there's some statistical learning theory
people here some numerical linear
algebra people have done this basically
the way you do it is you put a
probability distribution on your
inputs which you'll show has some sort
of universality property so whether this
is like law of large numbers these are
things like law of large numbers for
like random
matrices all right I also point out that
some of these results will hold for
deterministic designs py so we'll see
that at the
end okay so here comes a setup all right
so I'm going to do a setup with with
something very simple to at least to
start with I think it can be extanded
and could have some fun so here I'm
actually doing the expectation the
expected risk minimization problem where
I'm minimizing over my data and I'm
going to assume that it looks like some
expectation of f composed with a
transpose X so a here is my data at the
moment I'm going to assume it's normal
mean zero with a covariance
okay that covariance I'm just going to
assume is in operator Norm bounded
independent of D
okay uh this xar is just the extra
modeling parameters that you can have
you can think of it as like ground true
signal Etc uh the main point here is
that this little F uh I'm going to
assume is what is called pseudo lip
shits and it sort of is low dimensional
so I my data a is going to be high
dimensional the D is going to be High
dimensional so when I hit it with X it's
going to map it to sort of a low
dimensional thing so this F is somehow
low dimensional it's only the low
dimensional thing so in Le squar this
would be the equivalent of the x squared
part of it okay not the inner product
side yeah what is pudus yeah what is
pseudo lious I I brushed that under the
rug it just means that you still have
lipids right but you're also it's not
constant so it's not like f ofx minus F
of Y / xus Y is bounded by a constant
you can allow that constant to grow in X
and Y so it's polinomial in X and Y so
it gives you a little bit more freedom
allows non-convex objectives you don't
it's not just
linear I think it fails is sort of
exponential
stuff big question sorry I snuck that
in cool okay so what does this allow it
allows you to do glms multi-index models
so here after you take the inner product
it's sort of low dimensional M here
would be your number of classes this xar
can represent a bunch of different
things it can represent ground true
signal mean of data some fixed Vector
I'm just giving it some more modeling
power in this
okay and what do you see so let's look
first at one pass SGD so here I'm not
reusing my data so what the idea was one
pass SGD is that you generate at each
iteration a new data point a uh a and
Epsilon epsilon's the noise and you
update based off of that okay so here
I'm just plotting what that would be and
what you see surprisingly is that for
large models so where the D Over N is
growing both are getting larger and
larger so the number samples and the
parameters are getting big but going to
some fixed constant that you actually
get concentration that is to say the
entire risk evaluated at SGD is actually
concentrating around a completely
deterministic
function okay you can analyze this
function and it's completely determined
by Spectral properties of the covariance
of that
Matrix that's what you're seeing in this
picture so what I'm doing here is I'm
running SGD iterations divided by D okay
so I'm resc SC ing time I'm doing
logistic just doing KL okay what I'm
doing is that I'm generating a d is
equal to 100 for fixed n size so the D
Over N is constant generating and
running this and Computing 10 INF it
runs and this the the Shaded region is
the the variance of those Reds okay and
I'm going to increase each time so now D
is 400 again D Over N will be constant
so I'm also increasing n okay and you
see that the variance across the rounds
is shrinking and finally it's shrinking
all the way down so that you actually
get a theory which is just some curve
which is this red
line so there's a predictive
curve
okay so why does this work so why do you
actually even see concentration the
first reason you see this is because
there's a lot of extra averaging which
is going on in the problem itself so one
of the places you have extra averaging
is that you have this compositional
structure of a transpose X so a is very
large x hits it this actually is
averaging out in D it's doing some sort
of sum process going on that's why you
sort of expect things now the other
thing which is kind of funny funny about
this is that lots and lots of the
statistics that we're interested in
actually take some specific form why do
we need this if we actually want to
predict the behavior need something
which is like uh that we can evaluate
things on so if I form this W which is
where I concatenate X and xstar lots of
your statistics that you're interested
in are functions of what w transpose Q
of KW Q here is some
polom Okay g is just some low
dimensional function of so lots of your
functions can be represented as W
transpose q and KW so if I write this
out it means that I have these four
things here
okay so examples of this are the risk
itself like all your distance to
optimality the things that you measure
things for optimization and Norms of
gradients are all represented in this
form
okay so everyone clear this so just to
give you an example because it's a
little bit hard to see let's just look
at this so let's look at Lea squares
it's the easiest to kind of start with I
can represent LE squares is a trace
expectation over a trace I do my
expectation out I get something which
looks like x- xar transpose kx- xar so
you see X transpose KX that's appearing
that is one of those things those form
okay everything else also X star
transpose KX that was also one of my
forms and the trace the G would be the L
the trace part of that
function it works for logistic
regression you can do exactly the same
thing okay why does it work for logistic
regression it's a little bit harder to
see but the idea of why those statistics
are appearing is because if you take a
to be a normal say and you hit it with X
well a transpose X has covariant X
transpose
KX and it has oh sorry it has a yeah
coari and the cross terms between it has
the X transpose KX star so this is why
these statistics are important overall
why they they appear so if you know this
then you can write this just in terms of
X of these X transpose KX and X
transpose KX stars and
Etc you can also do little two- layer
neural network things again for the same
reason that this that this has the form
of something which just involving X Plus
KX star these will
also so what does this mean it means
that because most things that we're
interested in have this very specific
form we only really need to understand
the behavior of w transpose Q of KW
that's it if we understand that we just
apply our low dimensional function to it
and we get everything else from it so
all we need to understand is the
Dynamics of this property of this
function now there's a slight problem
with this the problem with this is that
you actually need to do it for every Q
okay it's actually a lot of cues every
polinomial and that actually turns out
to be too big of a space there net
arguments if you know some some high
dimensional probability stuff and so
this is problematic so there's a fix to
this that people know about and one of
the fixes is that instead of looking at
this thing we're going to look at
something which involves something
called the resolvent of a matrix so
we're going to form W transpose
resolvent of KW what is the resolvent
the resolvent of a matrix is where you
take Z minus K inverse and Z is just
some element in the complex
plane everyone okay with
this any questions have I lost
everyone with resolvent okay so why is
this useful this useful is because this
resolvent actually encodes everything
about polom actually encodes more why
does it encode it it encodes it via
Koshi integral formula so you can always
represent W CH with Q KW as a contour
integral over the function Q of Z with
the resolvent so knowing the resolvent
gives you everything about Q actually
gives you more the analytic
function so now that's the idea the idea
is that as long as I can write down a
formula for this Behavior which which is
like nice and compact it has only a one
parameter family with these then I be
able to represent all the Dynamics of
everything and that's exactly what you
can do okay so before I do that I need
to introduce my time scaling so in order
to get the concentration to work I'm
going to rescale time and the way I'm
going to do it is by Dimension so if K
is representing the iterates of SGD
that's the K's it of SGD I'm going to
represent that by T * D so I'm going to
discretize my time by
Dimension okay T will be my continuous
parameter D will be my
Dimension okay everyone okay with that
not step size dimension the important
part here and then you can prove exactly
what you want you can show that along
the entire path s of SGD will actually
con concentrate around a completely
deterministic
function okay and because all of our
statistics are of this form we can
recover that we can recover information
about this and so we also get that any
statistic that we're interested of SGD
is actually concentrating around a
deterministic
function sorry I went back this
deterministic function of s will be an
OD so we can represent it by okay an OD
that's fully representing SGD it's going
to account for the noise that SGD
creates and the statistic you can just
recover directly by doing this G and
Contour integral yeah CH K proportional
because you're taking proportional yeah
yeah yeah uh it has to do with the time
so you when the number of samples
because I'm not reusing samples in this
case I will reuse samples but if you re
uh if you're not reusing samples then
you're you can only go out like number
of samples so time is like proportional
to D which is proportional to n
yeah do you have any assumption about
the voice like the empty no yeah but you
do assume that you you your sample is
fixed like your sample from a fixed set
of data or something this I I will do
that this one is just a a a normal zero
but with any coar structure normal with
zero withar I will remove some of the
normality uh but the the coari the way
you do it you can think of a covariance
can be whatever it wants to be okay I
see yeah thank you
yeah all right um I just also want to
point out you get central limit theorems
so it's actually you're proving that the
entire curve the path is actually a
central limit there
concentrating um from this result okay
how do you do it okay I'm hoping to
bring stochastic processes back again
okay so the idea behind this is we're
going to create another process
continuous time process which matches
SGD okay in a special way so the first
thing I'm going to do is I'm going to do
like continuous time process that we've
seen before but I'm not going to
discretize with respect to step side I
want to make my step size large as
possible so what do I have to create my
continuous time as I mentioned before I
have Dimension so K iterates of SGD is
going to correspond to T times the
dimension so that's how I'm creating my
continuous time process K Over D is my
continuous time D is very very large
that's why this will not work in
dimension too but it will work in
dimension a thousand a million Etc quite
well then the second thing that I'm
going to do is you traditionally do with
stochastic process theory about
stochastic approximation is you try to
get your new stochastic process to have
the same mean and covariance that's the
general approach the problem with doing
that is that this covariance of SGD is
so complicated you just can't work with
it it's it's just too hard even for Le
square if it's too hard to work with so
what do you do instead you steal another
trick from SD Theory which says that you
can often average out or reduce the
diffusion coefficient reduce the problem
with the covariance of
SGD okay and you decrease it by looking
at Dimensions so you simplify using
dimensionality using averaging technique
to reduce this coefficient in front of
the browni and
motion it's called homogenization it's a
technique that's used throughout SD
Theory
what do you still want to preserve you
still want to preserve that fee of this
new process is roughly fee of
SGD so any statistic of it is preserved
under but you don't need to match mean
and covariant okay so what this means is
that the iterate that I generate from
this is not going to match the iterate
of SGD but any function of it is an
imine moreover again I can keep my step
size as large as possible
so what this means is that if SGD
diverges this process will also
diverge that they match each other okay
because it's all
Dimension and you can prove that indeed
this is the high-dimensional equivalent
of SGD that is to say any
statistic of SGD will concentrate around
any statistic of this diffusion process
overwhelming
probability
okay any
questions on
this but I lost everyone so the main
idea here is you can actually use this
to find stepsize stuff yeah
statement is that last statement uniform
on fi or you need to fix the statistic
uh it's well okay for any stati it's not
uniform for any okay the constant here
will depend there's a constant in front
of this will depend on the statistic and
it depends on like the lip
property any other
questions okay got a little bit of
everything for everyone all right so how
do you actually get deterministic
equivalences how do you actually get the
deterministic function once you have
this process you just can do EO calculus
on it so if you apply EO calculus
because it's continuous you just do
calculus now you get two terms one which
is exactly representing gradient flow of
same behavior that's like the mean term
and the second term is the actual
representation of SGD noise this is
actually what SGD noise does for that
statistic the other thing you get is an
extra Martin
gilter okay that's because of the
brownie emotion part um and so if you
look at this you might be like okay what
is going on here but actually these two
Quant ities can be represented as some
function of that Matrix plus the Martin
Gill DB the grounding motion here okay
so out of all this I didn't write it
down it actually turns out that all
these things can be represented through
this statistic this
s and so you might just play this same
game and say well why don't I just let
FBS okay so if I let BB S I get that DS
is equal to G of S Plus the Martin SC
term which you show is small in
dimension which will disappear in
dimension and so now you just say well I
can just find the deterministic thing by
just letting my deterministic thing be
the solution to this
OD without the mar go and that's all you
do so you can show that D of s is G of s
you can numerically solve that and you
also can play the same game with any fee
and get it so this will be the
terministic equivalent for
BC and that's exactly what you can show
you can show that fee under any
statistic is equal to fee of that
diffusion then fee of the diffusion will
concentrate around that deterministic
equivalent and if any one of these
processes diverges the other diverges is
theia so they match up
everywhere okay
and their concentration is pretty fast
inde D so by a thousand you will see
this of course we don't care about
solving these problems and you mention
two so it's fine so this goes back to
this question well that's kind of cool
you can solve these but what is what do
you gain from all of this so one of
these things you could ask is like well
what is the choice of learning rate
which decreases say a distance to
optimality
condition at each iteration of SGD well
you obviously cannot do that was
gradient was SGD directly because of the
stochasticity but you could ask the same
question of the deterministic function
now it's completely
deterministic you can ask well when does
the deterministic equivalent of the
distance be a monotonically decreasing
function okay and so you can do that so
you can play the game you know that the
I'm letting the script D be the
deterministic equivalent of distance to
optimality say you can write down what
it OD it has to solve it can be all
represented by low dimensional things
you can write and you can optimize that
and say when does this thing be less
than zero that would mean I decrease at
each iteration my distance to
optimality and you can write it
down that is so I just want to point out
a few things these a ofs and these I ofs
which appear in this formula are always
about little s so they carry almost no
no information about K and D okay
they're completely low dimensional
they're like X squ okay low dimensional
12x squ okay so you can often lower
bound these a and I just based on
smoothness and convexity of f little F
which is easier to compute the other
important thing that you see is that the
average I value of your ciance naturally
pops out of this expression and so the
point where where you're seeing a
decrease versus not a decrease is
actually occurring at the average igon
value not the largest igon value this
naturally gives you your average I value
of per in the case of Le squares just to
put this all into perspective the lower
bound Q is actually just two and so you
get this critical value of two over the
average I value VAR exactly what you
want and you can prove directly that
this thing diverges or converges at
exactly that point that step size just
directly from this
analysis
okay you can also get convergence rates
from this so doing this if you have
little F so this is not the full full
loss but the just the inner function is
M strongly convex and lpes you can get a
convergence rate and the convergence
rate now is not depending on the largest
I the the condition numbers that we're
used to it's actually depending on the
the average condition number is what
pops out which is exactly what we've
seen in practice the average condition
number it's playing them a more
important
role it works it's kind of fun this is
the best experiments in your life these
things actually just directly are on top
of each other you never have to do
anything so here I've played around with
logistic regression and what I'm doing
is I'm just plotting the last iterant so
I'm writing this for like x50 of SGD
okay and I'm plotting various different
learning rates and what I'm doing is I'm
changing my covariance by fixing the
average I can value the trace but
letting the largest ion value grow just
to get a sense of it and what you see is
that they all sort of hit at this one
point where this is like where you stop
decreasing and it's exactly all the same
value because I've averaged out the
trace I mean the trace equal to
one this is actually
working okay you can can do this with
multipaths now so what do I mean by
multipaths so I'm going to focus now on
Le squares because a little bit easier
to work with oh by the way sorry maybe I
should stop are there any
questions should pause
here have I lost
everyone
okay okay um you can do this for Le
squares and you can do this for
multipath now so with the Le squares I'm
just here I'm explicitly putting the one
over n and my loss here is some sum over
these guys okay um my a I'm going to
view as having entries order one my B is
entries also of order one okay and what
does multipath do is now instead of like
generating a data point x I'm generating
you know selecting an index uniformly at
random so that's where my Randomness is
coming from okay and I'm updating my
gradient just based off of
that so here I'm reusing my data so I
can go over and over and over again my
data and what you see again is that for
very large models okay as D Over N both
grow okay that the loss evaluated at SGD
is going to concentrate around the loss
of a deterministic function it's
completely determined by the spectrum of
the Hess and you can write down a
formula and analyze
it that's what you're seeing here so now
what I'm mapping on the the denominator
here is epox so each when T is equal to
one it's like going once through my data
set that's the same sort of scaling that
I had before and again you see this
concentration if I generate randomly
these A's and I do these curves right
you see uh a variance which is
decreasing as as my uh Dimensions get
larger
okay how do you you can also start to
remove Gan assumptions okay you have
some fun uh how do you do this you can
actually allow your model size to kind
of grow so you actually don't need the D
Over N constant you can actually have it
grow a little bit of
polinomial um how do you what is what is
actually the key thing that is going on
with these a a normality that you're
actually really using in at least in
these squares in particular is that
you're actually using something called
the delocalization of the igen
vectors okay what does that mean it
means that your igen vectors tend to be
uniformly distributed on a
sphere okay the classic example of this
is if you take entries of your Matrix to
be normally distributed you form a a
transpose then they're done on the
sphere but this property actually turns
out to be true for lots and lots of high
dimensional random matrices lots of
random matrices basically igen vectors
don't have that much information in
it that's the idea in high dimension
most of the information is in the
Spectrum okay you can represent you can
check if something satisfies a
delocalization property using ideas from
random Matrix Theory okay and just to
give you a sense of what else actually
satisfies this so the way you think of
these by the way is these are
universality properties of large
dimensional random matrices they're like
Central limit theorems about IG values
igen vectors all this holds so examples
include sample covariance matrices so
provided that your data is independent
but you have any covariance on your
feature side it satisfies this random
features also satisfies this lots and
lots of things
satisfy
and it turns out under that assumption
you can actually prove again and you
construct a a a a stochastic
process okay which is given by this
formula right so you do the whole
homogeneization effect so the idea here
is that instead of the expected you just
replace all the expectations expected
risk with their
empirical versions and where you see
covariance you would replace it with the
empirical covariance that's it it
works okay so you can do the same and
you again see that you do indeed have a
deterministic equivalent and that for
functions of it you get that Fe of SGD
will concentrate around this diffusion
and this diffusion will concentrate
around a deterministic function now for
deterministic design so I just need my A
and B to satisfy properties involving uh
delocalization any questions I lost
everyone good
yeah uh yeah
okay okay there's a reason at the time I
we we were only trying to get this for
the loss it's true for things Beyond it
it's basically true for C3 function the
C3 this weirdly is because of um EOC
calculus to do you know calculus
essentially need C3 yeah you're still
going yeah you're still going through
the resolvent two together exactly yeah
yeah you always have to do some form of
a resolvent computation because of
uh yeah you do the resolvent Now using
the resolvent of the empirical
H any
other what if you you go go back to what
if you go back to the discrete Dynamics
do you still have this nice property
like you know the dependence on the
condition numb than so long yeah it
exactly matches yeah and it only gets
better as Dimension growth so and it it
basically the concentration is so
because it's it's just the concentration
in dimension the concentration will hold
at like 100 or like thousand so if that
is true then is it possible that you
don't resort to all this
continuous Dynamics tools you Pro
directly the I mean this is sort of
discreete in some sense because I'm
still keeping D's in there so it's not
the Astic it fails to start to hold when
D is like two or 10 or things like that
your bounds get really they get bad so
it won't hold in those but okay when D
is large you know that these two
processes are just close and so you can
use one with the
other yeah and it were the discrete it's
it matches exactly the
discrete it's really nice you should
discretize in dimension not in Step size
that's the key yeah oh this is just a
clarification question so there's
Randomness in the like the the data
right A and B yeah are you assuming
Randomness and also how you select the
indices for the SGD update at the moment
I'm just choosing them uniformly at
random okay yeah you you can start to do
it it's much much harder so there's a
natural question it's much much harder
to understand the randomness that is
generated when you like fix a
permutation and run through it and
compute the
Dynamics it because it essentially the
problem with these things is that uh the
covariance over time of the iterates
gets more and more complicated it has a
more and more complicated dependence on
the
data that's the thing here the
covariance in the covariance over with a
uniform really is actually quite simple
over time it looks like this after doing
some averaging
now um but if you have a different
choice of IND like how you choose your
indices this gets more
complicated this is like the meat this
is like what that choosing an index
uniformly at
random so if you had a different
strategy then you want to have something
as nice as ATA potentially yeah this is
it gets much worse yeah yeah that's a
great question what what is that I mean
if you just did it directly instead I
wanted to check the covariance of the
iterates of sdd even with this multi
path using this index thing like using
this choosing uniformly at random and
index that
covariance of the iterance of SGD
directly is awful it's still awful what
allows us to do this simplification is
that you have to use high dimensions to
reduce it some of those terms will
disappear in the
dimension and there's averaging going on
and that averaging effect like you have
things which like a transpose X starts
to appear that's an average that you
need to use to help you reduce the
covariance term always it's just a
trick I don't know if it's a trick it's
a a way to simplify the process so that
you can actually get in get information
cool okay any
others they L know okay um in the case
of Le squares it actually simplifies
even more so instead of having to look
at all those statistics you just
actually have to look at one statistic
which is the loss and the loss will
determine everything from it and the
loss actually solves something called
the convolution volara equation so the
loss will have the deterministic part so
sorry the loss of SGD will concentrate
around the deterministic loss and that
loss will actually self solve each other
DET it solves it so the the
deterministic gloss is actually just
equal to the gradient flow plus a term
which is mixing with this is what your
the loss is appearing again on this here
is actually What Choosing uniformly at
random and index does to SGD this is
what that is doing and it's exactly that
and it's exactly a convolution vola if
you've never done vola equations they're
in your classic intro OD book go back I
teach Odes so now I make my students
know it it's in your OD book it was in
renewal Theory it's been around for a
long time everything about it is well
known okay you have things like kernels
appearing so the kernel is just all it
is is it involves just I values of your
your hessen Matrix your your empirical
covariance okay that's with this kernal
thing here and your forcing term is just
the gradient
flow what's beautiful about this idea
with convolution volter is that
everything is known about it we know
exactly when it converges when it
diverges Etc so because of this
equivalent we can just say Well when
this diverges then we know SGD diverges
and in fact if you use that it involves
kernel Norm bound then oh sorry this
should be L sorry switch notations L
here you know that this the
deterministic is bound if and only if
SGD is bounded and from the proofs of
how when you know these things are
bounded from very classical OD Theory
you can actually generate the whole
average Trace two over the average Aon
value pops out it's exactly
that you just use OD Theory really OD
oops oh oh wow I oh sorry what else you
can do with this is that the loss it
didn't matter what like the function I
could have plugged in any function
remember it holds for any statistic of
it so now what you can do is you can run
your X case using SGD on the training
and evaluate and compute a deterministic
equivalent for the risk the actual
expected risk and plot the two so that's
what I'm doing here I'm plotting the
population populating streaming one pass
versus if I actually use multipath
deterministically I can put know what
SGD is going to do and what you see here
is that as and if you had streaming
something like say you had n is equal to
2,000 so you only had 2,000 samples on
the streaming you would stop at that
value but on multipath you would go down
and go up and so what you can actually
do is exactly predict how much
data when you start to or like how do I
say this you can actually predict uh uh
when should you reuse data like when
should you actually do a multi path for
streaming setting because you have
complete deterministic two OD functions
for it you can exactly do
that I just want to point out this
really does work you can't check these
properties of delocalization but you can
just plot put in real data sets and
totally predict everything so this is
with edness you can predict the training
You can predict the expected risk
totally
predicted okay they exactly
match you see weird things in Step sizes
I'm GNA run out of time sorry you can
see the weird functions of Step siiz
Behavior so what you see in the step
size is that there's a a phase
transition and you can exactly plot it
what that means is that there's a choice
of Step size for which on one side of
the step size your convergence looks
like gradient descent or look like a
gradient flow and on the other side it's
noise dominated and if you can exactly
predict what that will look like and it
has a different form and at this jump
point it's not smooth I a phas
transition there and here you see that
so you can see these for for various
step
sizes um I'll just briefly mention this
you can also do this idea if you wanted
to for mini batch and stuff like that so
here I'm doing the exact same formula
but now I'm going to allow The Zeta to
be my batch fraction
okay and I can do SGD multipath with
momentum let's say I extended it so you
can do it you still have the same
concentration results your loss will
concentrate around a deterministic
function this function is now discret
because of the mini batch Behavior the
mini batch actually makes it a discrete
so instead of getting an integral you
get a sum here but it has the same thing
you have gradient what you get is a loss
which is is evaluated at sort of like
gradient descent full backat and
something which involves the kernel and
repeat it
again um what's beautiful about this you
can analyze everything and you can
finally answer questions about uh
stochastic momentum you can choose
exactly choose near optimal parameters
because everything's deterministic now
can always work with a deterministic
function okay so you can choose and you
know exactly the effect on the from the
mini
batch
and the idea is that again the average I
or average condition number will play a
different role than the largest
condition and what you can do is then
you can start to ask questions about
well mini batch sizes so one of the
things you might say is I'm going to
define something called the implicit
condition ratio which is the average
condition number over square root the
cap Square the classic one and when
you're in the large batch which I'm
saying is that my batch fraction is
actually bigger than this value SGD with
momentum looks like deterministic full
batch SGD with a full batch momentum and
you get a one over Square capital rate
when you're under this value you look
like
SGD what this says that something we've
all known about is that there's a
saturation effect which is that adding
more and more to your batch eventually
doesn't improve convergence we can now
quantify exactly when that occurs is
that this this simple value average
condition number over square root if
your back fraction is bigger than that
you're going to get one full batch if
it's less you're going to get
SGD okay so it exactly captures that
behavior
right and it works it really does work
you can plot different batch fractions
you can plot s of the last iterate and
so as you increase your batch fraction
what these gray things are exactly the
icrs for these things on real data and
they're exactly predicting you see you
go down and then all a you flatten out
this is a saturation effect you don't
improve anymore by adding more to your
bch and this thing is actually really
doing a good job of predicting
that and then I'll just end and say
thank you and here are all these papers
and there's lots of questions involving
this I didn't even put I didn't put any
up here because there's just too many so
I'm happy to answer any more questions
so thank you
any more questions
recordin yeah just to understand a bit
better so let's say that you can do the
mini batch in like one step because it's
I don't know parallel right so what is
the setting of the mini like what is the
setting that I should set the bad sides
to have the best realtime performance
the fastest real and convergence is it
exactly that point yeah for momentum it
is yeah yeah so if you're doing this is
exactly exactly where that occurs yeah I
see perfect than that's the other way of
thinking of
it at least from a convergence point of
view this yeah so you know if you're
optimizing over something else for your
mini batch it might not be like a
cute oh yeah I was saying like you have
run yeah yeah yeah yeah thanks cool yeah
um so you may not be able to answer this
but like in dropping out that Martin
gaale is this really just for dealing
with browni and noise is that like the
only application or if it was some other
color of noise can we also it's not
other it's for every it's for all color
noise we're not really dropping out the
marale again the idea is that you create
a two processes so you're creating a pro
two processes and whose mean and
covariance are are sort of the same okay
and one way to and then that's actually
all that survives in the high dimension
all the other extra terms like anything
other higher moments will disappear when
Dimension gets large basically that's
the idea so you're not really dropping
out and it's not really brownie motion
it really is representing SGD noise
you're not assuming anything on the SGD
noise
yeah
are we good any other
questions so uh H how does maybe I
misinterpreted the result but the the
fact that you can make progress
proportional to one over square root the
average condition number as opposed to
the worst case how does it not like how
does it not uh contradict those you know
the classic lower bounds that based on
chish polinomial is that you know one of
a root K is the best progress you can
make where K Kappa is like the the worst
case condition yeah yeah yeah it's
because it's because when you're in so
so it goes back to high Dimensions so
when you're high dimensions and you have
stochasticity it goes back to this
question here
actually when you're in full batch this
is actually grad L and it's like I'm
pointing in that One Direction I see
this
stochastic is like actually most of your
directions from your stochastic are
orthogonal to the direction that you
actually care about they have nothing to
do with the full gradient Direction
that's important that's why you get
average stuff average iing value starts
to appear That's the pro that's
basically what's
happening thanks yeah they really you
you have to think of them as two they're
not the same you cannot do full batch
deterministic optimization has nothing
to do with stochastic now and high
Dimensions small high dimensional it
looks very different very very
different all right so let's than
courney again
B and we'll take a break for lunch